this is a production of Cornell
University
well thank you especially to jean-luc
for inviting me here it's a pleasure to
see all the exciting work that you're
doing so this is a again work that I did
during my postdoc with Ben McCloskey
some of you may or may not know him he
was in nature sorts of genetics and like
me he's an operations research person so
essentially an applied mathematician at
some level he was a deterministic
optimizer graduated I believe out of
rice and a postdoc at Columbia before he
was hired and to help with the
optimization routines inside major
source genetics and so we actually
interestingly met at a conference the
big conference for our area is called
informs the Institute for operations
research and management science and we
started talking and he had plant
problems that were relevant to the kind
of solution techniques that I was
working on and then we discovered we're
both in Cornell so we might as well
collaborate and so we did so this talk
is a little bit difficult to give this
is only the second time that I've given
it to people who know more about plants
than about operations research so it is
a little mathy in places because I'm
used to giving this to an Operations
research audience but I would rather you
ask questions and interrupt me and I'll
skip some slides if you get totally lost
there's a chalkboard here so I want you
to take away something from the talk
rather than hear myself talk if you get
too lost so I'd rather this be informal
this is quite formal room but it's not
too different than the one I teach
probability in so raise your hand I'll
try to repeat the question I think we
might have some people online and we
have a chalkboard so we can go at
whatever pace is comfortable for you
so I have prepared two tutorials one is
aimed at plant breeding people to say
what is simulation optimization in the
first place so that's the first little
bit of the talk the second tutorial is a
tutorial on some mathematics that you
may
unfamiliar that I give to everyone
including operations research people and
then we'll get into the plant reading
part so we'll kind of have two little
presses and then we'll go back into the
main problem that we're going to talk
about okay so for now I'm going to
assume that you have heard at some level
of optimization and so what do we mean
by optimization this is a farm
management example at the plant breeding
conference
Bilby this went before me and this was
his example and I stole it because it
was amazing so he's not here to explain
it to you but essentially you want to
maximize profit and you have some
decisions that you can make on your farm
right so you can decide how many acres
of wheat corn and beans I'm gonna have
to use this for a pointer so in this
notation the X is the decision vector so
the X's are things you can decide so how
much wheat corn and beans you can plant
how much you sell what price you how
many beans you sell at a lower price and
how much you purchase and so on and then
you can formulate this we have a linear
objective so the profit function is just
a linear combination of the decisions
that you make and you have some
constraints so for example the
constraints might be that you can't
plant more wheat corn and beans then you
have acres if you only have 500 acres
then that's all you can so this is a
classic farm management type problem in
fact many linear optimization methods
were developed to solve these kinds of
problems and they're very old
and so they're easy to solve we can
solve them they're deterministic so to
speak so the profit model is linear we
have no uncertainty whatsoever and this
may be a good model for your farm it may
be that you've been making decisions
with this model and everything is going
great and so this model is of sufficient
granularity for your choices you don't
need anything else but it may be that
this model is failing you for some
reason and
maybe what your plant is not what you
yield in the end maybe the price that
you thought you could get is fluctuating
a lot in a random way and so this model
may not work anymore you may need to
incorporate a different model with
randomness and so you can formulate
profit right now my profit will become
random it's a random function of these
things that I don't know I don't know my
yield but it's gonna be I don't know
what my prices are going to be and so
the only thing I can do is try to
maximize my expected profit so that
means that in any one year I don't know
how I'm gonna do but I want to do well
on average across many years right so I
have to deal with this uncertainty in
the yield and price and I formulate a
profit function it's still a function of
all my decision variables and the random
yield and the random price now and I
want to maximize the expected profit
okay so now I've turned what was a
linear model into something that is
stochastic at some level so the ultimate
goal is to maximize this expected profit
and I still have my constraints on my
decision variables sometimes that profit
function gets so complicated that we
don't have any closed form for it so you
can have stochastic optimization
problems before it this could still be a
linear function and I have random
variables in that linear function that's
possible but sometimes maybe you have a
really complicated climate model that's
going to tell you your yield and maybe
you have really complicated market model
from some finance people that's going to
tell you about your prices and so now
this thing gets extremely complicated
it's maybe a high-fidelity model it
takes a long time to run it and so you
embed the whole function inside a
computer and so you have essentially a
Monte Carlo simulation where you decide
some decision variables those are your
X's you decide what they are
you query the simulation model and you
say okay if I decide these decision
variables to be at these values what
will my price be or what will my profit
be in the first year do it again same
decision variables what will my profit
be in the second year same thing again
third year so on and then you're trying
to construct an estimator right
construct an estimator of your expected
profit as a function of this uncertainty
where all of your function is
essentially living inside of a black box
and you can only observe it with noise
so it's it's corrupted by noise so to
speak and have collapsed the constraints
that we had into this notation X there
are still some constraints we know them
but our notation is just going to
collapse them for simplicity so this is
called a simulation optimization problem
I have a simulator that has the function
embedded inside of it
I can query it at any decision vector
value right so I I determine how much
wheat corn and beans I want to plant and
then I query it and then I change that
and then I query it again but I want to
actually optimize this function right I
want to find the decision variables that
allow me to do well on average and so
simulation optimization is optimizing a
nonlinear function not necessarily
linear anymore
it's complicated with uncertainty it's
living inside of a Monte Carlo
simulation so I develop general
algorithms to solve these kinds of
problems for different kinds of decision
variables your decision variables might
be these happen to be integers right so
if if you are going oh sorry Akers I
missed a KERS so if there are a KERS
this will be a continuous decision
variable potentially or maybe discrete
depending on how you choose the model it
you can plant 500 acres you can plant
550 acres and so on you can divide it up
however you want between wheat corn and
beans so if
I'm sitting at a decision a particular
decision point right how do I know which
direction to move to get to one that
might be optimal and optimal in what
sense optimal in expectation which is
all I can tend to do when I have such
randomness okay so I develop general
algorithms for these kinds of problems
and it has had major impact so these
algorithms have been used by a group at
Virginia Tech that solved a vaccine
allocation to control an epidemic in all
of Seattle where they modelled at the
person level so they had a network of
people and they said I have some
elephant some vaccines but I can't
vaccinate everyone but I have a model of
every person in Seattle who should i
vaccinate to make sure that my expected
deaths from the epidemic will be lowest
as I can get them over the time horizon
and so this is a huge problem and we've
been able to solve it or the people in
Virginia Tech have for this kind of with
these kinds of algorithms that we can
develop another application is brain
computer interfaces so you have some
person who is connected through their
brain to a prosthetic arm or some other
prosthetic robot type limb and they will
think about how they want to move the
arm and you have to take the brain waves
from the electrodes and then figure out
how they want to move the arm just by
reading the brain waves and so there's
been success in doing this as well a lot
of other areas emergency services
financial modeling and portfolio
optimization manufacturing and supply
chain transportation have all seen major
impact from simulation optimization and
hopefully also planned breeding as we
learn to incorporate these techniques so
simulation optimization is a powerful
tool and I like to think of it as
sitting at the interface of three areas
so optimization is
traditionally deterministic you add in a
statistical component and also computer
science and you have simulation
optimization which is abbreviated esos
sitting right here in the middle so we
pull on ideas from all these disciplines
and sit in the interface and as you may
expect these problems solving them is
difficult right we have uncertainty we
may may or may not have gradients we may
not know in which direction to move so
we have to deal with sampling efficiency
and proper control of stochastic error
are the key aspects of these algorithms
we have been working in this area the
work has been developed for about over
30 years and single objective simulation
optimization problems are beginning to
have mature algorithms developed for
them multi objective simulation
optimization so for example if you have
two objectives and you want to identify
everything that is Pareto optimal this
is just getting started and so we'll
talk some I actually started working in
that area because of the work that we'll
talk about today with Ben McCluskey it
turned out that the problem that we had
was by objective and so we had to create
new methods to solve that problem ok so
now we're in math tutorial land so now
is a good time for questions about
simulation optimization what is it what
do we do
ok nothing yet quite clearly excellent
all right so now we'll get a little
muddier so this is a brief primer in
what's called large deviations theory
and I've written here if you get lost
we'll go through it but if you get lost
the key point is an unlikely event
occurs and the most likely of all the
unlikely ways so we're going to be
analyzing events that are unlikely and
we want to think about how they might
happen well the most likely way is how
they're going to happen at some level so
that'll
the Northstar when we get there but you
deal with things like ordinary
deviations all the time that's the
central limit theorem right so the
central limit theorem says if I'm
estimating a mean then my standard error
essentially is going down as order 1
over square root n right and I will
converge if I scale my x-bar correctly
and I have some assumption satisfied
I'll converge to a normal zero it turns
out that large deviations is another
regime where we're worried about
deviations that are larger than you
would typically worry about in a central
limit regime and so ideal
many times in asymptotics but as you
know by the central limit theorem even
though it's an asymptotic result it can
be extremely useful it can limits can
kick in quickly you can get a lot of
guiding principles by doing an
asymptotic analysis so what is large
deviations we know that if we have
independent and identically distributed
random variables x1 up to xn finite
variance and you construct the sample
mean in the usual way we know about the
strong law of large numbers that die
value is converging with probability 1/2
the true mean you all right so let's
graph this what's going on I have a
value mu and now in large deviations
theory I'm going to be concerned about
the probability that I observe a sample
mean much bigger than some value that I
care about
eh right so if I take some sample in one
and I plot the probability density
function of the sample mean x-bar for
this sample size in one it might look
like this
and if I want the probability that my
sample mean is bigger than a well I'm
just gonna integrate under the curve
it's this ok so if I take a sample in 1
the probability that X bar is bigger
than a is blue now let's increase the
sample
if I increase the sample and I have an
in - that's bigger than n1 then my
density function gets a little Center
remember strong law of large numbers
it's converging to a point mass at MU so
I have a little bit less area here and
if I increase it further it shrinks more
so large deviations theory that we're
going to be talking about it's saying at
what rate does this area go to zero
because in the limit my x-bar is
converging so the probability that I
observe a large deviation event that my
x-bar comes all the way up here and it's
estimated as bigger than a is going to
zero and we want to know at what rate is
it going to 0 as my n tends to infinity
so this picture is helpful as long as I
have a light tailed distribution right
so my moment generating function is
finite then I have ignored this for a
moment just look at the bottom we're
saying the probability that my x-bar is
in some interval a to infinity so I got
that large deviation event and I observe
my x bar way out there it's
approximately e to the negative n which
is my sample size times the rate
function evaluated at a so I can move my
a around right so my a could have been
anywhere in here let me go back to this
picture if I move my a over here or move
it up here the rate is going to change
right because that tail probability is
falling differentially depending on
where my a is so I can plot the rate
function for all different values of it
and we'll do that on the next slide but
essentially this is saying right so the
infimum this is called the rate function
i of x over x and a in anytime you see a
theme I'm just thinking minimum it's the
smallest value is I have a so now we'll
come back up here we're going to see
things that look like this negative
limit n goes to infinity 1 over n log
probability X bar in a to infinity do
the math in your head take the log
/ in moving negative / get a limit and
you get the eye of a [ __ ] out the
other side so that's all that is we're
saying under some conditions the rate of
decay is exponential and we're going to
be talking about optimizing this term as
a function of the sample size in
hopefully this will get clearer when we
do an example so it turns out rate
functions are non-negative and convex
convexity is good we like convex and
they bottom out at zero at the mean
right so X bar will always be either
side of zero of the mean right so the
rate there is zero but it goes up on
either side for normal so imagine the
normal probability density function you
have that e to the negative 1/2 X minus
mu over Sigma squared that's what's
coming down here as your rate function
for a normal random variable so what's
going on here remember our compass is
going to be the unlikely event occurs in
the most likely of all the unlikely ways
so my X bar I'm worried about it being
bigger than 8 but my X bar can be
anywhere it could be at 3 or it could be
at 4 it could be at 200 but what's the
most likely event X bar is Right today
right so the most likely way that I'm
going to see an X bar bigger than any is
to observe X bar at all the rest of them
are way way less likely I think that's
enough to be dangerous yeah so it'll
make your rate function a different
shape this is a particularly nice
quadratic rate function for normals it's
symmetric but if you think of other
distributions you may have a rate
function that that comes down and then
goes way up
or has a different shape or asymmetry it
will still be convex so having that
shape it'll still always have the bottom
the minimum occurring at Nemean with a
value 0 so if the rate function form
depends on the distribution okay so now
you are you all know about large
deviations unlikely event occurs in the
most likely of all the unlikely ways so
why do we care about this
why would we be interested in large
deviation events in a context where
we're estimating things so let's suppose
that we want to pick the parent pair
that produces progeny with the largest
expected biomass you may have some
problem like this and we can use Monte
Carlo simulation to simulate the
breeding and growth of progeny from
several parent pairs and we sample an
equals ten progeny from each of the
three parent pairs and we get box plots
that look like this so remember we're
maximizing so these two are better one
and two are better than three and so now
if I suppose that one is truly the best
so it actually has the highest mean I
don't know it yet we're interested in
the rate of decay of probabilities such
as X bar two and minus X bar one is in 0
to infinity what does that mean that
would mean that my X bar - even though
it is not the best is estimated as
better than the best one so this is I
accidentally picked the wrong parent
pair as being the best one and I can
control this the rate of decay of this
probability so one thing that's very
interesting that comes out of a
literature called ranking at selection
is that ordering is exponentially fast
whereas estimation is slower estimation
I can estimate the true mean of this
parent pair of the progeny they're
producing as order 1 over square root
that's my standard error Sigma over
square root in and it's it's falling
much slower than being able to tell
which of one or two is better which are
of one or two is better is happening at
an exponential rate so you can order
them faster than you can estimate them
when you're doing simulation like this
so the tail probability were interested
in is for example X bar 2 minus X bar 1
is in 0 to infinity which looks like
what we saw before and notice that a
very tip will expand the notation later
but X bar - I may have different amount
of samples that I spend on parent car
wine versus parent part - in terms of
how I breed them right I might breed 10
from this one and 30 from this one right
I can do that
that affects the rate of decay right so
when we come back and we see this in
alpha right here in the exponent this is
going to be in scaled by the proportion
of sample I give to that parent pair and
it's going to become a decision variable
for us how much sample should I give
across these parent pairs so that I can
make their ordering happen as fast as
possible ok so even though this is we've
gone the route of math this is fairly
intuitive right if you got this plot and
you have current car one car to impact
or your parent / 3 is pretty bad and you
know it I'm gonna give you 30 more
samples you're probably not gonna give
10 10 10 right parent / 3 is already bad
we draw their differentially sample to
figure out who's better between one and
you we've just put some math on that
concept it's all we've done that allows
us to analyze it and rigorously say what
is the differential sampling scheme that
we want to use so that is where we're
going we'll head back into plant land
for a little while
more comfortable so suppose a farmer
wants to grow one extreme individual
this is the problem that Ben had he
wanted to figure out given a population
of reading parent pairs for example we
we buried the genetic effects just for
simplicity we considered pairs as units
on their own we have a single growing
season and then the question is how many
progeny should be planted from each
parent pair so that we maximize the
expected maximum biomass we observe in
the field so we're going after that one
biggest tallest largest plant and idea
then would be to propagate that into
future generations so again we'll borrow
math so we're given some breeding budget
B and we want to maximize the expected
maximum over all of the parent pairs and
all of the children we breed from each
parent pair of this random variable
which is my yield so each child from
each parent pair function of whether
function of whatever happens in the
field we observe this yield and so we
want to maximize the expected maximum we
see subject to that we can only breathe
so much in total which is B and we can
choose how much we breed from each
parent pair as we go along so a total of
X I children will be bred from the eigth
parent pair Y IJ of C is the observed
trait of the JS child from the parent
pair and the uncertainty could be due to
anything you have in your model so
genetics soil conditions the weather
whatever each planting plan is assessed
through Monte Carlo simulation and the
granularity of the simulation that we
used is that you essentially take a
parent pair simulate it out pops of the
child and so you get one observation
from the progeny trait distribution of
the parent pair so that's the unit at
which we are simulating
so this problem evaluating the objective
function with high precision may be
expensive because what do I have to do
let's suppose that I choose to breed
equally from all the parent pairs that I
have and that satisfies my budget
constraint well that's one potential
solution so I put that in my computer
and I say ok now tell me what is the
maximum of the first replication so I
did one trial and I got a maximum yield
okay now I have to do that again and
then I have to do that again
and then I have to do that again just to
get an estimator of this objective
function at that particular greeting
scheme and then maybe that didn't do as
well as I wanted now I have to play with
it these are my decision variables the
X's are what I can decide because I have
to change it so our our whole problem
was how do we make this tractable how do
we actually solve this on a computer in
a way that is manageable feasible set
may be large you can do a lot of
different things so Ben was telling me
that a lot of his colleagues kept saying
well you're gonna allocate everything to
the one best parent pair that'll be one
best and you're gonna give the entire
breeding budget to that one and it turns
out that this is the correct answer but
only if your trait is Bernoulli so the
trait is there or not there so something
like disease resistance you're resistant
or you're not and so you will have your
Y IJ will be Bernoulli P Bernoulli is
like coin tossing there's some
probability of success each time you
toss the coin and so if each parent pair
is producing children that are Bernoulli
with some value P that depends on the
parent pair then we can prove that the
solution is to identify the parent pair
with the highest probability of
producing that resistant offspring and
then give everything to them so this
devolves into what's called a ranking
and selection problem because you don't
know this probability for each parent
pair you'll use Monte Carlo simulation
to try to figure it
out and we're trying to assign
everything to that so if you're
interested in this problem we do have
methods for that in terms of the
operations research audience we decided
to go with a slightly more complicated
model he was worried about traits that
are normally distributed and it turns
out that for normally distributed traits
you will not necessarily give everything
to one so let's take an example remember
the Y IJ of C are the traits of the
individual children they're iid normal
with mean that depends on the parent
pair and variants it depends on the
parent pair so if we have parent pair
with normal mu 1 0 Sigma 1 is 50
compared to is mu 2 is 50 Sigma 2 is
0.01 right so I have one sort of fat
distribution that is wide high variance
but low mean and then I have another
distribution that is high mean but low
variance it turns out that I am going to
split the allocation across these
parents so if I give everything to the
low mean distribution here then it turns
out that my expected max is 42 something
like that estimated expected maximum we
have small standard errors we had to
simulate this these results if we give
everything to the second one then I'm
going to hit that high mean but I'll
have it'll be very near to 250 good
question so we found we don't actually
have numerix on this in particular but
we found that it's somewhat dependent on
the breeding budget so this was
constructed specifically as a
counterexample
so that Ben could say not for normal and
say we have to do something else
so it depends on what the breeding
budget B is it turns out that if you let
your breeding budget get very large you
are going to give all to the high
variance parent pair why is that so if
we look at the split allocation that
happens to be optimal we're going to
give one to the high mean low very
inexperienced there why because we want
to secure the high mean we can give one
and get a high mean with pretty good
certainty so we want to give one there
the other two we're going to go for
broke on the high variance parent pair
because the high variance parent pair
has the potential to produce with higher
probability parents out here or children
out here in the tail so I'm going to
give one to secure the high mean on the
you two and then I'm gonna give
everybody else trying to get that
extremum in the tail and it turns out as
your breeding budget gets really big you
will give everybody to the high variance
parent pair because you're going for
that tail always it doesn't benefit you
to give a lot to the lower mean one or
lower standard deviation one so in terms
of how does it actually work out I can't
I'm not entirely sure but I can tell you
asymptotically where I don't know yeah
often with the data that we had giving
all to one was an optimal strategy but
it wasn't always so we are taking
parents separately as a pair right so it
would be this pair produces children
with this distribution and this pair
produces children with this distribution
oh I see what you're taking so I think
you're talking about how did I get these
parent pairs in the first place is that
right your because one of the highest to
get back pair so if you have the ability
to control how variable this is and you
have an infinite breeding budget yeah
you will you will try to maximize this
variance and then allocate everything to
it yeah no that could be a very large
breeding budget okay yeah okay so
hopefully I think I've convinced you
that the alter one strategy is is not
always optimal at least in the normal
trade case in term yes if you could
change these parent pairs and inch this
one further you'll probably be
allocating something to it because it's
all of a sudden it's producing your best
even though it's lower variance
for yes as opposed to multiple traits we
have yeah just one trait that was one
extension right so we're we're going to
avoid or attempt to avoid simulating at
least that equal allocation the entire
population to marry related that
conditions you can anything I'm going to
go yes so this would be putting some
kind of neighborhood structure on the
feasible space so this we do not have a
neighborhood structure we assume we
don't have one that would be an
extension that may help so we took a
different route of assuming that the
parent pairs are not ordered and they
don't have neighbors
which may be an oversimplification but
good point yes yes where you could
sample at one and then say well I know
that the people or the plants near me
are going to be similar in certain
respects okay so this is this is a tough
problem to solve so we started thinking
about how do we how do we simplify it
how do we get something that is more
tractable so it turns out that as you
may have guessed from the previous slide
if a parent pair has a mean and variance
that is dominated by some other parent
pairs mean and variance you will never
simulate or you will never get any of
the breeding budget you may have to
simulate to figure out what the meaning
variants are but you will not allocate
anything to it because it's neither
producing that extreme individual nor
going for the variance so efficient
parent pairs are non dominated in terms
of their mean and their variance and
only parent pairs on the Pareto front
will receive a planting budget nonzero
in the original breeding problem that we
talked about so the goal then is to
somehow identify those on the Pareto
front so this is just an example data
set that then had were created where the
Pareto parent pairs are sitting right
here they're represented by circles so
how do we identify this one two three
four five parent pairs that have the
best mean and variance values and you
may then wonder well wouldn't it just be
the corner points wouldn't these ones
the extrema be the only wants to get
allocation and again I set my computer
running and I have a counter example for
that too
so prove our counter example is is the
way to go and we have a counter example
so you may allocate something for
example to this one
and so you'd like to identify the entire
Pareto front so what does that give us
it gives us a reduced set to consider so
when I'm trying to solve that original
problem I don't need to allocate across
20,000 parent pairs anymore I only need
to consider allocating across something
less than or equal to about 25 pairs so
this is reducing the dimensionality of
the problem dramatically if you can
identify those pareto parent pairs that
are dominated in terms of their meanings
so we proposed a two-step solution to
solve the mating design problem so in as
a total simulation budget that you can
use we're gonna choose enlarge and use a
simulation to obtain estimators for each
parent pair and we're going to construct
an estimated Pareto set so we'll call
that P hat that's a function of my
simulation budget and then we're gonna
solve an estimated version of the
breeding problem it's we're calling it
problem a hat sub P hat of in this is
just a grief formulated the expected
maximum using the fact that we have
normal distributions so if you don't
recognize this don't worry it's just a
parametric form but I don't know the
mean and the variance in here for each
parent car so I'm estimating it so I'm
just using plug in estimators for all
the values that I don't know and I'm
evaluating it only over our estimated
creatives so we're going to predetermine
the the estimated mean and variance
values in my simulator and get the
estimated proto set and then solve this
problem only on that set and it turns
out that if I let my sample size in my
simulation go to infinity then I will
get the true optimal breeding budget
allocation plan out of this problem so
the key is going to be simulating enough
that we can get these Pareto parent
pairs efficiently
so the nice thing about this we could
have done other techniques we could have
done something for an integer ordered
space but the nice thing about this was
that if the breeding budget changes we
don't need to re simulate so after we
run the simulation studies you can
change this B to be anything you want
and it does not affect what happens to
my estimated mean and variance values so
that's nice because if you're still
unsure how many resources you have you
can do the simulation in advance and not
have to redo it over and over again the
other one that was a benefit Ben
mentioned that the breeders were not
amenable to just implementing whatever
one solution pops out of the simulator
you need more than one they'd like to
see entire the entire Pareto front for
them would be nice to see what are the
good contenders and then allow them to
incorporate other knowledge they have
that may not be in the model so you can
present to them the entire Pareto front
that you've identified and then let them
select from among those so reducing the
set of parent pairs only do the Pareto
front reduces the complexity we have
this master planting allocation problem
this problem a hat sub P hat and then
created a specialized branch and bound
algorithm just for solving this after
we've observed the estimated mean and
variance values out of the simulator so
you'll simulate and then solve this
problem but now we have a sub problem
which is how do we find the set of
estimated Fredo parent pairs efficiently
and then there's a simulation sub sub
problem which is how do we allocate a
simulation budget in to find the
estimated pareto set P hat I change the
notation here it's no longer a function
of n this is called multi objective
ranking and selection and this is sort
of how I got my start in working in this
area because all of a sudden we need to
identify parent pairs that are on a
Pareto front and so this question is the
one where
the simulation optimization you know and
we get excited when we see problems like
this so how can I create my simulation
budget allocated to the parent pairs in
an efficient way
and remember this is ordering right I
want to get the order right so if I have
a procedure to estimate the pareto set
and is my total simulation budget and
I'm gonna let in alpha I be the
proportion so alpha is the proportion of
the total simulation budget that I give
to the ice parent pair for estimating
their mean and variance values and at
the end of simulating I'm gonna return
the estimated greater set right so now
how can this go wrong well it can go
wrong if one of my parent pairs that's
actually on the Pareto front it's miss
estimated as not being there that's an
ordering issue just like we talked about
in the tutorial or if one of the parent
pairs that is not in the Pareto front
jumps in again an ordering issue and so
I want to find a simulation budget
allocation that maximizes the rate of
decay of the probability that a parent
pair is misclassified this is a large
deviation of inch that a parent pair is
misclassified and the unlikely event
occurs and the most likely of all the
unlikely ways so in order to figure out
what this simulation budget allocation
should be we analyze how likely all
these events are so that's where we're
headed very briefly and it gets a little
nappy but I think you can follow so
equal allocation is what they were doing
it's expensive it's time and money
Ben was running his experiments on
Amazon and so you have to pay for those
servers and if you're just going to
brute force equal allocation it can take
a while so can we do something that is a
little smarter so now we are living in
the sub sub problem of allocating the
simulation budget to get those Pareto
Perry pairs so some
notation and alpha I is the proportion
of sample allocated to parent part I we
have the estimator of the mean and the
estimator of the variance we're going to
assume normality so now we have the
estimator of the variances chi squared
so in a lot of the work that exists on
these types of problems
everything is assumed to be normal so we
needed special methods that will allow
us to use chi square random variables
and account for that in our techniques
and large deviations is particularly
suited to doing so how do we analyze
these events so we're going to analyze
it pretending we know everything and
then later we're going to plug in just
like we did when we didn't know what to
do in the master breeding problem we
just plugged in a new hat in place of MU
we're going to do the same thing here
we're going to analyze it pretending we
know everything and then we're going to
plug in to figure out how to allocate
our simulation budget so again how does
a miss classification event happen I can
exclude somebody by accident or I can
exclude somebody by accident the
unlikely event occurs and the most
likely of all the unlikely ways so I
have to figure out which one is a higher
probability of it so in a large
deviations framework we're concerned
with the tail probabilities of these
random variables that my Y hats change
places on the mean objective or that my
Sigma hats change places on the variance
objective and I'll go a little fast so
it's the minimum of these two rates is
the one we care about we have to analyze
them separately and it's going to come
down to a pairwise rate so it'll be for
exclusion it's the minimum of the
pairwise rate that one paredo excludes
another I'm going too deeply about each
mathematical expression MC I turned out
to the the MIS classification by
inclusion we had an issue analyzing this
because of dependence so we had to
reformulate it and do some
more math we came up with these things
called phantom Pareto parent pairs where
we can write an exclusion inclusion of
it like an exclusion event and analyze
it the same way math math math here's
the rate okay so the unlikely event is
happening in the most likely of all the
unlikely ways this is MC e this is MC I
miss classification by inclusion and
miss classification by exclusion and so
I'm going to look at every pair and I'm
gonna say which one is the most likely
one to exclude or include and between
every pair that is going to determine
the entire rate of decay now remember
decision variables in this our elephants
I can decide what proportion I give to
each pair of pair so those are my
decision variables so I want to maximize
this rate of decay subject to my authors
have to sum to one I can only get 100%
of sample in total and this is a concave
maximization problem in alpha which we
like which means we can solve it easier
so what if I solve this then it turns
out I have some constraints we use a
solver what's going to happen I have a
hundred parent pairs here an optimal
simulation budget is calculated as a
solution to this problem where my
decision variables are alpha the
proportion to allocate to each parent
hair in my simulation experiments so if
I do this and I make the size of the
circle proportional to the amount of
allocation that each parent parent gets
we're going to shift it toward the
Pareto front so before I was doing equal
allocation so this guy gets as much
sample as this guy no that's not smart
instead who's going to potentially be
misclassified well these guys are the
ones I care about being misclassified so
anybody that's really close to the
Pareto front needs to get more because I
have to decide are they in or are they
out
relative to their whoever's nearby this
guy is bad and I know it so I don't need
to sample very much so essentially what
I'm doing is I have all these pairwise
rates of decay of these probabilities in
this classification that can happen and
the Alpha is going to equate the rates
the optimal alpha will make sure they go
down all at the same rate will give me
an allocation that looks like this and
so a few more examples of shifting the
sample up toward the Pareto front so
again we don't know Mew and Sigma right
and we need them inside the rate
function it turns out that the rate
function knowing that is equivalent to
knowing the entire distribution the mean
the variance everything so if we don't
know that what will we do well to
implement this we'll take some initial
amount from everyone the reason we have
to do that is because we don't have the
neighborhood structure we have not
assumed that so we have to get some
estimator of how everyone is doing then
we update the sample means and sample
variances we update the estimated pareto
set and we solve an estimated version of
the optimal allocation problem to get
that simulation allocation for each
parent pair we use that as a sampling
distribution from which we take the next
delta progeny and we keep doing this so
we keep updating our optimal allocation
as we go this way so for this allocation
it turns out that we do better than our
competitors there's only one competitor
in this area it assumes all normal
distributions
I think the just the difference that we
have from our competitors that we're
actually able to deal with the
chi-squared directly we didn't go into
detail on what's different about that
but the rate function was different and
it turns out that it allows us to do a
little better and so we have some miss
classification probabilities that as my
simulation budget is going to infinity
our our allocation is doing much better
at controlling misclassifications it so
imagine that you just give equal
allocation instead of
doing something intelligent well your
miss classification after a simulation
budget of 10,000 is going to be all the
way up here around two and a half
percent of your systems misclassified
but for the same simulation budget you
could have a rate of miss classification
around 1% so you can actually do much
better by pulling down these
probabilities okay and so this slide is
for the Ori people who don't know how
plant breeding works so this is
essentially saying what will you do in
your life you want to breed the largest
plant you'll consult with a company like
Nature sorts genetics you'll build a
simulation model you'll allocate and
intelligently at the end of the
algorithm you'll estimate the pareto
scent they'll estimate the mean and
variance values you'll decide your
budget you can solve the integer program
for the master breeding problem off
offline with regards to the simulation
because you've already done all of your
simulating in advance and then you
adjust and you breed in real life and
then you breathe the largest king grass
plant I have some one more slide with
questions you can ask me questions but
these are the questions that I have for
you they're sort of turn the question
section on its head before we have to
leave so the questions I had relate to
what kind of simulation models do you
have and what do you use
so there are plant level models like
this but there are also potentially
system-wide models climate that
incorporate climate these models can be
any level of abstraction so you may have
things other than individual plant level
simulations you can also think of
simulators in general so a big data set
can be a simulator so if you can't load
the entire data set in your memory well
when you're trying to estimate some
parameters it turns out that we have
adaptive
adopted stochastic gradient descent
methods now that will allow you to load
only a part of the data set to determine
if the current value of your parameters
is good or bad or get a derivative and
move to another point without having to
load the entire data set so simulation
Oracle it can be interpreted more
broadly than than a black box so to
speak
what are your decision variables what
values can they take is there a
neighborhood structure what are the
objective functions how long can you
take to make a decision many times in my
field we worry if it takes the algorithm
longer than a minute to run so if you
have 30 days this is incredible right we
can really do something but I it's my
sense that you'll run it for 30 days but
it better be right you don't want to run
it for 30 days and it's still wrong and
what kind of computing resources will
the user have access to will they be
running on a laptop on a supercomputer
things like that so as I've talked to
people I've gotten some sense of the
answers to these questions but these are
these are the big ones and we have maybe
a little bit of time for questions for
me
[Applause]
to invest it for you or so we're
maximizing both yeah yeah oh yeah these
okay so the idea I'm not trying to
extend your question but the idea is
it's it's harder to tell who's on the
Pareto front when you're close to it
right if I'm over here it's pretty easy
to tell that I'm bad so I want to
allocate more of my simulation budget in
the area where it might be good exactly
so if you have two current pairs that
are producing children with means and
variances that are right very close to
each other and you really want to get
the best one you're going to have to
spend a lot of sample to figure out
which one is the best one as opposed to
ones that are already exactly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so that I think the concise answer is no
but I I view that as sort of a human in
the loop where you would have some
knowledge that somebody corrupted this
data and now I have to fix it everything
that I've done so far assumes that the
model is correct the data was collected
correctly it's hard for an algorithm I
think because what's really going on
here
this is coming out of the simulator so
you would have already collected your
data and you would have already
hopefully cleaned it and built and as
correct simulator as you could get and
so we're assuming that what's coming out
of the simulator is at some level if we
keep sampling forever will converge to
the trees so even though that may not be
accurate there is so it's only just now
being developed in the multi objective
context in the single objective context
for this same problem if we just had one
there's something called an indifferent
zone and the indifferent zone is backing
up from the best by a certain amount and
saying if these two systems are within
or ferret pairs are within Delta I don't
care don't worry about detecting that
difference so there is some work in the
multi objective context it's a little
more complicated to specify when you're
in potentially high dimensions what that
Delta would be here you could imagine it
might be a box there is some work on how
to allocate so that you don't spend all
your budget trying to decide between
these two guys yeah so that is
definitely an issue but the key word
there is in different zone if you walk
around in my community and you talk
about in different zone everybody will
know what you're talking about so these
are different problems because I may not
know how many are in the indifference
zone right so if I if I'm maximizing and
I backup from the maximum there could be
a hundred in there verse is saying I
want the top M designs is what we call
ya and there is in one objective there's
also a lot of literature on getting the
top we call it top-down in multi
objective it's brand new so we don't
have those methods we could do that that
is one way to go I think one of the
reasons then did not favor that so the
question is we have this optimization
problem this one
not just sample to solve this directly
and we could the thing that will come
out of this if you do that is you will
get the optimal breeding budget and not
really any other information you'll get
the optimal breeding budget you'll get
the value an estimator for the value of
the objective function as well but in
terms of getting a subset of parent
parents that might be competitive you
won't get that you won't get estimators
for the mean and variance values of
those parent pairs and if someone
changes the breeding budget you'll have
to redo all the simulation so you and
because I enjoy integer ordered problems
this would be fun but I think in terms
of the specific context that Ben was
looking at doing it this way turned out
to work better yeah but good question
oh I think I see so we actually can
prove that if we estimate this set
correctly that none of the breeding
budget will go to anybody that is
outside the pareto set yeah so that was
a condition of reducing the feasible set
to this this value yeah but again you so
this all assumes your model is correct
and that is doing what you want it to do
because whatever's in this Pareto said
is going to depend on your model
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu